why is it that someone like Elon has got
himself to the stage where he can say
things that almost every other I don't
think he's got himself to that stage I
think he's always done that and so now
he still knows how to do it Steve Jobs
was exactly the same way which is why
the Apple products are such miracles of
technological Mastery same with Elon
right he's refined down what he does he
seems to have although the Enterprise
he's put together is unbelievably high
functioning to produce an automobile sub
industry bring down the cost of space
exploration by a factor of 10 and to
invent reusable Rockets he's probably an
alien yeah probably